Martin Scorsese wasn't kidding when he
said that his neo-noir psychological
thriller Shutter Island will be twice as
profitable because moviegoers would have
to see it again just to understand the
ending even a second of viewing of the
pic can still leave audiences confused
about what was actually happening to
Leonardo DiCaprio's character though so
let's walk through what went down on
that stormy Island and see if we can
make sense of this enigmatic movie
experience and of course there are
spoilers ahead finding the truth there's
still some disagreement over whether the
central character is actually named
Edward Daniels as he thinks or if the
doctors are right and his real name is
andrew laeddis but let's just call him
teddy to keep it simple after Teddy
arrives to the island with his new
partner Chuck who eventually claims to
be his treating physician dr. Sheehan he
slowly reintroduced to his suppose at
reality teddy is told that he shot his
wife after she lost her mind and drowned
their three children in his lake house
taken at face value it might seem like
Teddy has simply been repressing the
memory on a loop instead of shouldering
the blame for his wife's mental
deterioration and neglect he's convinced
himself that he's a US Marshal
investigating a patient's disappearance
on the island and by extension tracking
down the man who burned his apartment
with his wife inside that might be all
well and good for other people because
there are a lot of patients that are
left to linger in their own little
worlds but during his delusions Teddy
tends to exhibit dangerous behavior and
has been scheduled for a lobotomy as a
result dr. collie desperately wants to
avoid such a fate by letting him live
out his policing fantasy one last time
on a grander scale in hopes of making a
mental breakthrough that'll stick for
good knowing this makes certain earlier
moments make more sense like the fact
that Chuck struggles to hand over a
sidearm to the guards and the moment
when another patient loses her cool over
the mention of his suppose it real name
the doctor seems to be unsuccessful in
the end as Teddy appears to relapse once
again but there's a reason to believe it
may have actually worked this time
because he tells Chuck which would be
worse
to live is a monster on a day is a good
man
she and himself seems to recognize this
as a moments have failed loose it is a
but as he fully embraced the reality
they've given him or is there an even
darker truth that everyone's been trying
to hide another reality even if Teddy
has come to terms with his crime it's
still possible that he actually did
something worse than what he's been told
the warden who visibly hates him and
doesn't seem as on board with the
experiment effort as others makes
mention of the fact that Teddy's
committed terrible atrocities in his
time but even the memory Teddy's said to
be suppressing isn't bad condemning if
his wife really did drown his children
and had become so far gone that she
wanted to place their lifeless bodies at
the dinner table then his reaction is
relatively sympathetic so some theorists
believe that story may have also been a
fabrication considering his wife is
shown turning to embers earlier on in
his dreams the movie seems to suggest
that she actually did perished in the
fire have burned down his apartment had
previously believed and since he was
convinced it was a man named Andrew
ladis who lit the match he may have also
been correct on that front too even if
he just didn't realized he was after
himself the whole time that would
certainly explain all the symbolism of
his use of matches in the jail cells and
his pyro treatment of Corley's car and
it would also suggest a perhaps those
three children whose photos were thrust
in his face at convince him of the story
were never actually his after all he did
see the same gun in the wreckage during
his flashbacks to the war and he never
sees the children floating in his lake
until he's shown those images which
means choosing an out if Teddy did cause
his wife's demise by fire he may have
done so in a moment of post-traumatic
stress stemming from his service in
World War two killed a lot of people
as he saves throughout the movie he has
been overwhelmed by the depravity he
witnessed while storming the
concentration camp and taking out the
guards even though they were
surrendering to his troops because of
his extreme guilt and inability to
accept the crimes committed Teddy may
have chosen to manufacture a false
reality in which he is a u.s. marshal on
the hunt for his wife's attacker
meanwhile his doctors may still have
conjured up the story about his wife's
criminality in order to make him feel
better about what had actually done in
hopes of him living out his days on the
island and relative peace after all
Teddy's probably not alone in his PTSD
from the war and maybe he's just a
patient zero and trying to find a humane
way to handle soldiers who do terrible
things as a result of their mentally
taxing experiences overseas if we fail
as you and everything that we've tried
to do here we'll be discredited
everything in the film's much-debated
final scene that elaborate brainwashing
project appears to have failed with
Teddy outwardly assuming the role of US
Marshal once again and because the
doctors are unable to bring Teddy back
to reality they have no choice but to
lobotomize him however what we really
see transpire is Teddy choosing to be
lobotomised the doctors aggressive
roleplay may have actually worked Justin
not in the way they hoped perhaps the
reason Teddy seems to accept the
controversial surgical intervention is
that Teddy does in fact remember that he
burnt down his apartment building and
with his wife inside he may also know
that even if the alternate scenario is
true he still attacked his wife at the
lake house and lost his three young
children either way the pain is too
great to bear considering his being
confronted with two possible truths
about his past violence and can live
with neither of them his choice to
embrace the unknown seems pretty
understandable thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]